ich glaube in der folge kommt es zu
beginn des blogs erstmal richtig
erfreuliche sache ja ich habe übrigens
mit abgeschlossen
ich habe in meiner wohnung wieder
aufsetzen ich bin ein konkreter was sich
allerdings gerade sagen wollte meine
lieben freunde ich habe ich hier im
schlafzimmer einen schrank wo ich gerade
nun kann ich darin gelagerte allerdings
ist mir aufgefallen dass ich hier
klimaanlage haben
das krasse ist es ja gerade irgendwie
der sommer zurück gekommen ist von daher
ja vielleicht sollte ich älter als 30
grad stellen zu von dummheit baum
gefallen oder was asm kaputt herzlich
willkommen im neuen blog gegen die
übrigens wieder der sommer in
deutschland ausgebrochen und das auch in
hamburg auch in den west auf jeden fall
kommen meine ganzen sommer
terrassenmöbel 75.000 quadratmeter große
daran komme erst im winter an weil ich
geld sparen wollte und mir gedacht habe
ich hoffe dass jetzt nicht im sommer
sondern dann wenn es keiner kauft kriegt
bestimmten paar vattenfall überlegt was
könnte man denn so als übergangslösung
geschaffen für diese eine woche jetzt
noch mal richtig gutes wetter in
deutschland eine luftmatratze
wow der blog ist schon fast zwei minuten
und handel bisher nur von luft
derweil trotz der form einer klimaanlage
und von der luft aus meinem arsch ich
habe übrigens noch eine stelle in einer
wohnung in hamburg deswegen erst davon
so tüten und irgendwie auch ein
kamerastativ beim umzug verloren
gegangen deswegen nutze ich eine tempo
box
[Musik]
mit ernährung zu tun
naja eigentlich ernähre ich mich relativ
geworden schaut euch die letzten tagen
nur pizza und burger gefressen
wahrscheinlich hätte ich gesagt heute
steht übrigens wieder in meinem leben
meine lieben freunde gegenseitig das zu
beginn von jedem block und dann passiert
immer nichts das ist so wird es spannend
was heute passiert ich mache müllbeuteln
über die mülltonne also schon beim
ersten wegen dem anderen youtube kann
man das verbraucherrecht ihrem video
sammeln das problem in meiner wohnung
ist übrigens auch dass wir nicht
irgendwie was machte an der
arbeitsfläche und hier ist mit bacchus
und er hat touch und ich stehe wirklich
einfach nur dran er einfach an wegen
meinem knie was macht er jetzt ober
unterhitze 180 grad wahrscheinlich will
ich etwas runter ist ohne dass sie
tragen keine ahnung was hat ist ich
glaube kalte hände wahrscheinlich kalte
hände ein ich bin entspannt habe mir
heute voll viele gläser eine innenstadt
in hamburg gekauft und auf einmal sagt
die so am ende an der kasse
dadurch dass jetzt so viel gekauft dann
haben wir noch ein mega schönes präsenz
für sie da werden sie echt mega darüber
freuen
ich denke vielleicht kriechen geilen
champagner dazu oder irgendwas anderes
was kriege ich eine tasse kaffee tasse
mit dem logo vom unternehmen drauf danke
für nichts kaputt gegangen auch dabei
das ist übrigens mal im kellerraum
das ist ein rohre die sind in etwa
genauso lang wie man hat jetzt mal
brauchen wir den sexuellen witze nie
ganz teilen sogar das ist der raum und
genau so richtig auf
ich will es nutzen
ich hasse wäsche zusammenlegen
ich hasse erkältet sein
ich hasse es geblendet zu werden
ich hasse es wenn mein handy
[Musik]
ich weiß dass ich kein stativ habe
ich hasse lebensmittel online bestellen
irgendwie zieht das leben gerade an mir
vorbei und ich hasse alles und willst du
was ich am meisten hasse vor geist wir
spielen wieder nur zweimal in der das
toll auch nicht sein
die spö sich den kindern kommt es
irgendwann 3
[Musik]
hier kommt einmal auf meiner seite das
ist ihr nächstes
die haben auch gut hier ein jungs lassen
sich auch nicht drücken hier
naja wird durch die kicker was noch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so so finale noch mal 4
das ist absoluter unsinn abschnitt muss
ich mir immer das nicht gemacht wird ist
auch noch letzten ganz klar
[Musik]
wir sind noch immer an bord
in alle fünf wieder werk spitze auf ein
neues kommunizieren
ja natürlich legal angeboten nein
scheiße
[Musik]
nämlich ernst was meinst du nicht ernst
was zur hölle ist da die elektrode in
folge ohne wasser und herbstmeister in
medias uns gerade gegangen und ich habe
wirklich drei kronen geholt ja danke auf
jeden fall kommt jetzt eine freundin rum
und wir kochen was zum ersten mal in
meiner wohnung sehr sehr will ich auch
in pkws stellt euch das mal vor ich
offenen pelikan am strand beim
sonnenuntergang
ihr könnte mich glaube ich ihnen
verhalten an der stelle ist der heutige
lockt jetzt allerdings auch vorbei meine
lieben freunde und ich würde sagen ich
beende das ganze mal wieder mit einem
witz main kanal kurzes update noch eben
zum ende des plots
jetzt werde ich dann habe ich mir gerade
wenn auch was für meinen blog
ja ich muss ganz kurz einmal sagen dass
ich doch keinen pelikan als hosts möchte
weil pelikane wenn die sauer sind sehen
so aus das war ich noch kurz noch sagen
[Musik]